DHT or distributed hash table, is an
implementation vehicle for a content distribution network
to populate the routing table at the
user level. As I mentioned earlier, for placement
you need a put operation. And the put operation is going to take 2 parameters, a
key, and a value, and the key
is some content hash that uniquely identifies something
that the user community may be interested in finding.
And value is the node ID where the content
is stored. And retrieval of a key value is
done using a get operation. And when you do
a get and give the key, what you're expecting
to get back is the value that is associated
with this key value pair. So, what you get
back is a value that is associated with this key,
which was placed somewhere using the put operation. So using the put and
get operation, let's see how to construct the routing table as new content gets
generated. That is, you want to do placement of key value pairs using
put operations, and retrieval of a value
associated with a key, with this construction.